also die Maske als ich damals noch im
Gulli gelebt habe bei Splinter und den
Turtles damals habe ich mir die Maske
aus einem Stück Metall das runter
gespült wurde in der Toilette mit einer
pile die in eine andere Toilette
runtergespült wurde gefeilt aus dem
Block
Metall klingt das irgendwie mysteriös
und genug für dich
gut und die W Geschichte das war die
wahre die wre Geschichte wird gerade vor
Gericht ach so vor Gericht verhandelt
wie die wre Geschichte wirklich
ist rbustter einen wunderschönen guten
Tag du hast gefragt hier ob es nur eine
Maske gibt oder mehrere es gibt nur eine
also die silberne Maske die ich immer
aufhte das ist eine einzige Maske von
Anfang bis zum Ende gewesen dann hatten
wir aber irgendwann noch ein ein Ersatz
ein Backup gemacht die war schwarz mit
der konnten wir machen was wir wollten
also die konnten wir auch mal bunt
machen und so und im halt dein Maul
Video vom letzten Album sieht man beide
Masken die schwarze und die silberne